what was it like when they had the
ladies of wrestling back then because
remember that horrible they put those
Danes in there sometimes you know and
everybody looked like they were like
Angry Jazzercise yeah yeah no that
didn't float it was it was a nice Theory
and concept but
did y'all to travel with those ladies no
no you never saw them I saw lady
wrestlers in the old days but it's a
totally different thing and it and they
were badly managed and mistreated as a
midgets were I mean the midgets got paid
nothing really that's terrible yeah
that's why
anything I could do to help them
Transportation wise and that or buy them
drinks and food or that or get them laid
get them a little yeah yeah that front
boy
shut up Lane
and what do you wear a cowboy hat yeah
oh yeah Google
Cowboy Lane
he's famous and was he the tallest I
think I think he's only 410 right
that's tall enough to [__] huh
Geo would you like him look at how well
they
yeah these are pretty small
dang you got nice hair on him huh yeah
the Cowboys 4 10 4 11.
four foot yeah yeah
oh if you show up to [__] at four foot
you got to really mean it yeah yeah
especially with a five foot nine jerk oh
wow
how do you even I mean I don't even
God I would have watched that man yeah
it's like scale of the mountain I'm
gonna watch that match dude or at least
like hanging up your uh putting the star
on the Christmas tree on yeah I have a
friend that was with a one-legged [__]
in uh Des Moines Iowa
[Laughter]
names we had a little person we had a
little person in our town and people
would always try and get him to like
tell them like they people always
thought he knew secrets and like magic
and [__] people are always like do some
[__] Magic Hey listen I'm so good I
used to get the [__] wrestling lady
that's hard really Cowboy Lane give me
lady that's a little something [__]
[Music]
yeah what kind of women would usually go
for that little fell long I can call him
right now
she run the Speedway Club in Charlotte
though
oh hello
the office of the government said the
midgets turned down and listening
they're laying a little joke girl they
want to ride with you it's like be my
Eldorado
[Laughter]
man so do you like hooking your buddies
up yeah yeah it was hard getting that
Tokyo was impossible to get lead but
really yeah so in Tokyo it was hard to
get him it was hard to get a little
person laid Yeah but uh hang uh Cowboy
Lang had a pretty good hang on so I
could sell that through again yeah yeah
odd boy I'd hate I mean it'd be so hard
I mean that would be
just you know
that's like a damn kettlebell
something like that
I mean if you even have half a pound of
of wiener on them on a little person
that's [__] yeah it looks a lot
bigger
and especially if you put the right
makeup on the side of it dude because
I'll put makeup on mine I'm making it
look you know you wanted the lights hit
it the right way
ladies everything
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one